in the opening scene we are introduced
to a high school girl named Kasai Mai
who was recently relocated to a village
due to her father's job transfer as she
wakes up she captures a view of the
Village from her bedroom window mumbling
to herself that she never thought she
would live in a Village afterwards she
prepares for her first day at her new
school making a personal commitment to
be a disciplined humble and sociable
student inside the classroom there is a
noticeable group of female students who
are seen discussing a new student from
Tokyo and plan to recruit her into their
group meanwhile a student named odagiri
Shino is called to the staff room where
a teacher informs her about kasai's
arrival Shino is tasked with helping
Kasai adapt to the school environment
she has chosen because she is also
relocated from Tokyo just like Kasai
Sheena then guides Kasai to their
classroom with the latter filming the
school corridors along the way upon
entering the classroom Kasai introduces
herself gracefully to her new classmates
and takes her seat during a break she
sits alone while the other students
gather in different groups she realizes
that she must start looking for friends
or else she will be alone in the coming
days she then takes out a branded purse
from her bag which grabs the attention
of the prominent female gang they
approach her and the leader of the gang
yuria starts a conversation it doesn't
take long for Kasai to warm up to them
she makes the gang leader Happy by
praising her hair as well as her name
even though it sounds like some sort of
infection but deep down in her heart
Kasai thinks that urea and her gang
members are stupid in the meantime Shino
suddenly experiences breathing
difficulties drawing the attention of
everyone in the classroom her friend
Sakai rushes to her friend to offer
support she somehow manages to calm her
down and when questioned about the cause
of her distress Shino reveals that she
is panicking because she is again ended
up in the same class with Kasai in a
shocking turn of events Shino discloses
that during Junior High School she had
been a target of bullying by Kasai and
her Gang This Revelation leaves the
entire class shocked and changes their
perception towards Kasai as she know
hastily exits the classroom a bewildered
Kasai follows her trying to find an
explanation for her accusations as she
approaches her Kasai recognizes her as
kumura a former classmate from Junior
High School who has changed her name to
Shino Kasai asserts that the people who
bullied her in the past were chiharu and
shiori not her in a flashback it becomes
evident that Shino was indeed subjected
to bullying by a group with Kasai merely
watching from a distance because of this
Shino is exacting her Vengeance on her
just then Sakai walks in and Shino
suddenly starts acting like a victim
seeing this Sakai tells Kasai to stay
away from her friend in the aftermath of
this event no one in the class talks to
Kasai the following day one of the
members of urea's gang shizuka returns
to school after recovering from an
illness upon entering the classroom she
notices Kasai a new face in the class
just as she is about to approach Kasai
urea stops her and informs her about
kasai's involvement in the past bullying
of Sheena all furious at this Revelation
shizuka pours water on Kasai and demands
that she apologized to Shino humiliated
Kasai walks out of the classroom
slamming the door unintentionally
injuring shizuka's fingers in the
process shizuka cries out in pain and to
further intensify the situation Shino
claims that Kasai had previously done
the same thing to her as well after
witnessing this the entire class shouts
at Kasai urging her to leave later the
class resumes but all the students are
busy chatting about Kasai the next day
Kasai arrives at school and discovers
some trash beneath her desk she collects
it and goes to dispose of it in the
trash bin only to find her notebook torn
into pieces there in response Kasai
grabs her phone and Records the
situation she then goes to urea's desk
and tears her notebook like she did to
hers urea confronts her warning her
against touching her belongings to which
kasira torts the same applies to you
during the break time Shino is seen
keeping a close eye on Kasai as a result
she learns where Kasai keeps her phone
when everyone leaves the classroom for
lunch she now goes to kasai's table to
steal her phone the following morning
Kasai arrives at school and promptly
extends her apology to shizuka for her
actions the previous day however shizuka
pays her no attention and enters the
classroom later on Kasai notices that
everyone in the class is watching her
video it turns out that Shino has shared
her Vlog from her phone to the class
chat group in the video Kasai vents her
frustrations about her new life in the
village and recounts her bad experiences
at the new school unfortunately this
makes the students dislike her even more
later during break time Kasai is having
her lunch alone when she is approached
by one of the classmates named Minami
Abe Minami Hans Kasai an invitation card
to an upcoming cultural Festival as she
is about to leave Kasai stops her and
tries to befriend her but the latter
hesitates to be her friend moments later
Shino approaches her and taunts her for
being unable to make any friends in the
next scene we seek his size sitting on
the bathroom floor in a completely
messed up state it appears that she has
once again been bullied by urea and her
gang a short while later Shino arrives
and seeing Kasai in such condition makes
her smile however her happiness is
short-lived as she soon starts gasping
for breath she rushes out of the
bathroom and takes medication to calm
herself down it turns out that Shino is
suffering from neuropathy and witnessing
kasai's condition triggered her
traumatic memories from Junior High
School Days afterwards the students
start decorating to school for the
upcoming event with their class teacher
Midori providing guidance as soon as
their teacher leaves the classroom
urea and her gang walk up to Kasai and
paint her face with a red color panicked
the poor girl hurries to the bathroom to
clean her face she now also follows her
and proceeds to taunt her saying that
this is just the beginning yeah we're
gonna paint your arms red too the scene
then cuts to the day of the festival
where all the students are enjoying
themselves when Kasai enters the
classroom urea and her gang start
bullying her as usual despite this Kasai
disregards them and proceeds to her desk
only to be freaked out by a pile of
worms beneath her bag frustrated because
I snatches shizuka's puppet doll and
tosses it to the ground before storming
away she decides to return home but she
is not allowed to leave the school until
the festival ends with nowhere to go
Kasai enters an empty room and locks
herself in on the other hand urea and
her gang Venture class to class in
search of Kasai after a brief nap Kasai
walks out of the room only to be
confronted by urea's gang they
forcefully push her back into the room
and lock the door from outside cause
side desperately Taps on the door
begging to be let out but the bullies
ignore her pleas and depart as time
passes it becomes urgent for Kasai to
use the bathroom but there's no one to
open the door for her once the festival
ends urea and her gang return to unlock
the door Kasai hastily tries to run
towards the bathroom but urea once again
pushes her back this causes Kasai to pee
on herself creating an awkward situation
for everyone
urea attempts to ridicule her further
but another student named chiho yells at
the bully group firmly telling urea to
stop in a fit of anger Kasai also takes
off her underwear and throws it against
the wall making the group walk away the
news of kasai's underwear incident
quickly spreads throughout the school
becoming a hot topic of discussion among
the students well at least she didn't
urea in her pants upon hearing this
Shino rushes to the bathroom and bursts
into laughter on the other hand Kasai
decides not to attend school that day
instead she goes to meet with her old
friends from her previous school and has
a wonderful time with them at the end of
the day one of her friends inquires
about her new school to which Kasai
responds that things aren't going well
her friend then suggests she consider
returning to her previous school but
Kasai tells her that she'll be fine
later that night Kasai decides to change
her appearance by coloring her hair with
her new look she returns to school the
following day leaving everyone shocked
by her transformation before long urea
approaches to mock her but this time
Kasai retaliates by making fun of urea's
hairstyle deeply hurting her feelings in
the afternoon teacher Midori calls urea
out of the class to have a word with her
she hands her a small note which
contains a complaint of a student being
bullied in the class afterwards urea
confronts the entire class demanding to
know who reported The Bullying to the
teacher this makes chiho nervous and she
was the one who did it seeing her
distressed Kasai bravely takes the blame
upon herself protecting chiho from
becoming the bully his next Target
enraged urea pours a bottle of black ink
over Kasai leaving the entire class
flabbergasted after school Kasai is on
her way home when she is approached by
chiho who expresses her gratitude for
saving her earlier she asserts that she
is completely Against The Bullying but
doesn't have enough courage to stand
against urea and her gang as they
Converse chiho reveals that she knows
shizuka from junior high school and she
is not a cold-hearted girl like urea
after learning this Kasai devises a plan
against urea and invites chiho to
discuss it over a cup of tea the
following day Kasai uses chiho's phone
to texturia and deliberately encourages
her to gossip about shizuka later she
asks chiho to steal urea's phone and
damage it so that she won't be able to
alter the messages after their classes
Kasai meets shizuka and discloses the
screenshots of the messages
urea sent about shizuka in these
messages
urea characterizes shizuka as a weak and
unintelligent individual expressing her
dislike for her initially skeptical
shizuka attempts to contact urea but is
unable to reach her because I then
persuades shizuka to distance herself
from yuria as she could potentially
become the next Target of bullying
frightened by this Revelation shizuka
runs away from there a short while later
urea hears a scream and rushes
downstairs to find shizuka lying injured
on the ground in the aftermath of this
incident the students talk about urea
being found near shizuka's body and
harbor suspicions that she may have
intentionally harmed her some girls
inquire about the incident from urea but
she chooses to ignore them one day shiho
confronts Kasai and tells that she will
never change her hurtful Behavior she
then proceeds to harm herself in front
of Kasai by cutting her wrists
unbeknownst to Shino Kasai has been
recording their entire conversation on
her phone the news of this incident soon
reaches the principal's ear and as a
result she confronts the class teacher
Midori about the ongoing bullying in her
class in response Midori contends that
bullying exists everywhere and that
students should face it by themselves on
that same night Kasai goes through all
the recordings she has collected over
time here it is revealed that Kasai has
been secretly recording all the
conversations and incidents she faced
with Shino she then uploads all of it to
a website and shares them with the
entire school the next day when Shino
enters the classroom everyone stares at
her in shock urea is also taken aback by
all those videos she immediately
confronts Gino and asks if all of this
is true but the latter is speechless
this makes urea realize that Kasai has
never bullied Shino after learning this
the entire class starts blaming urea for
picking the wrong target shortly after
Shino confronts Kasai and accuses her of
ruining her life in response Kasai tells
her not to blame others because one
should take control of their own life in
the final scene Kasai walks in front of
the class to address everyone she yells
at the entire class claiming that they
are all the real bullies because none of
them stood up against bullying and just
enjoyed watching it she also says that
she won't forgive anyone and curses them
to die after spilling her heart out she
storms out of the class while all other
students begin to collapse to the ground
one after another the moral of this
story is that if everyone is a piece of
then no one is not a piece of
it's like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching